[Music]
some farmers
buy their seeds from big guys every year
to plant
me i saved my own i'm a seed saver
[Music]
what do you think what did that set you
back it's an investment
i told you
[Music]
[Applause]
package for mr percy schmeiser
monsanto is claiming the canola you grew
in 97 contained a technology
in the seeds gene that they created
i never bought that seed test showed
substantial
who are those mine grandpa monsanto will
say that everything you grew
is their property you sure got people
talking stole my central seed
you know not a thief feels like you're
angling for a fight
will percy have to testify definitely is
that gonna be a problem
getting his driver's license photo is
too much limelight for him
mr schmeiser i'm rebecca salco i'm here
to help you with your case
you try to fight them on your own you
will lose they're tearing our community
apart
they go after anyone who speaks out
against them i get sued for doing the
same thing my family's been doing for
hundreds of years so you did do it on
purpose
you ready for this percy this is a
precedent set in case
there are thousands of people who want
to support you monsanto says obama's
rights don't matter
we gotta keep fighting hey first can i
get your autograph
no david and goliath legal battle
in a case where farmers around the world
are watching very closely
you've heard your story you're fighting
back you bring us home
1.2 million dollars that's how much you
are we're gonna lose the farm
if you win no farmer could ever be sued
for saving seeds again
that's grandpa we're going to the
supreme court is that something your
lawyers have advised
i haven't told them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you